now Rupert ultimately the biggest
questions lie in the field of
metaphysics the what is the ultimate
nature of reality why is there something
rather than nothing what is the nature
of consciousness and then kind of
science of spirituality basically do
their best to understand that that's
ultimately what we're here doing is
trying to understand that and a good way
to you've you've said this question
before a good way to begin your Atma
vichara self inquiry is by asking a
question what is my source where do I
come from
what is the door what is the genesis of
all of this what is my real nature and
you had a really good conversation with
Sam Harris as well because I think it
was a good way to juxtapose the
consciousness only with someone that is
also interested in spirituality but also
has a grounding in deep science and
materialism and so he kind of said in
return that there's a big temptation to
make consciousness the very first
principle and that he then said that
that would mean that consciousness then
subsumes cosmogony the Big Bang and the
reasons for that but then you counter
with the question what is it that knows
or is aware of your experience yeah well
I think there's there's good reason for
making consciousness the first principle
simply because it is the first principle
of our experience so why not start there
it's just an undeniable fact of
experience that consciousness or that
all that is or could ever be known is
experience and consciousness is the
fundamental and primary we prerequisite
of all experience so if we want to build
them
of reality why not start there it is the
primary element of our experience so it
isn't that scientific just to start with
something that is actually experienced
something that is real in experience
rather than starting with an abstract
idea namely the existence of something
called matter outside and independent of
consciousness which nobody has ever
found or could ever find or will ever
find because all it is ever possible to
find it's the content of consciousness
that to me is abstract
what what what to me is really um
realistic and scientific is to
investigate experience what it asked us
of what is the primary element of
experience it is obviously consciousness
and to build our model of reality based
on that rather than on something that is
abstract ok so the take is that the most
the ground or the most fundamental first
principle is experience and then that is
consciousness that is awareness and then
that is the nature of reality is that is
consciousness is awareness and not that
there is a big bang that happens 13.8
billion years ago and after the billions
of years of evolution of matter then the
complexity of body activity creates a
consciousness that is is there is there
a point of any synthesis there or model
of sorry sorry - yeah
that that model of reality is based on
the evidence of thought and perception
it presumes that what we perceive of the
outside world is Israel in the way that
it is presented to our senses
and that thoughts interpretation of
sense perception is correct and
extrapolated from this model of reality
we go all the way back to the Big Bang
but this is this idea is based on the
presumption that perception and its
interpretation through thought is
correct okay okay it might not be maybe
our senses don't yeah
maybe the combination of perception and
conception that is the finite mind maybe
they don't give us an accurate model of
reality maybe reality is filtered
through sense perception and appears in
accordance with its limitations in other
words the limitations that we see that
we believe pertain to reality
may simply be the limitations of the
perceiving apparatus the finite mind
through which we perceive we cannot be
sure that the limitations that belong to
our perceiving apparatus yes actually
pertain to reality itself how do we know
that we are not simply seeing an
objectifies ation or a reification of
the limitations of our own mind yes yes
after all when the activities of thought
and perceptions subside as they do in
deep sleep time and space also subside
when thought and perception begins again
when thought begins again time seems to
begin when perception begins again space
seems to begin and this happens every
every single time thought and perception
disappear objective experience
disappears every time it arises again
objective experience arises again is
that a coincidence could there be a
connection between I would suggest that
there is in these are those hints that
we
were mentioning earlier these most
simple hints in science there's Occam's
razor the most simplest is likely the
correct and in this case it's so in a
sense simple and it is so it's so much
like a hint absolutely I liked your
analogy your summary at the beginning
about the dream we are given numerous
hints as to the nature of reality and if
as you say we use Occam's razor
Rock'em said that of two competing
theories we should always choose the one
that makes the least assumptions so here
we have two models of reality one that
or reality appears within consciousness
and is the activity of consciousness
that doesn't make an assumption it is
actually our experience the second
assumption is that what we what we know
of reality is generated by something
outside consciousness namely matter and
indeed gives rise to consciousness in
other words it the second theory
suggests that that which is never
experienced namely matter independent of
consciousness gives rise to that which
is alone experienced namely
consciousness so this this makes an
enormous assumption the assumption of
the existence of something outside
consciousness well if it was necessary
to appeal to the existence of something
called matter in order to explain our
experience then it would be legitimate
under Occam's razor to refer to such a
substance but it is quite possible to
make sense of our entire experience of
reality referring only to consciousness
in the way that you suggested with the
dream analogy and it this consciousness
only model also not only enables us to
make sense of our
perience of reality but enables us to
make sense of many phenomena that the
matter model does not is not able to
explain so their consciousness only the
model has a far greater explanatory
power and the matter model if we were to
visualize the Ouroboros the snakes had
eating its tail if we were to envision
the wholeness of that then is then the
the infinite consciousness is then
present at the oh it's present
everywhere but it's present at the
Godhead and the tail in the sense that
the tail portion this model of science
that currently is that many of us agree
to in consensus enjoy the benefits of is
at the detail point infinite
consciousness is at the tail point and
the Big Bang is the process of the tail
point itself still evolving over time
into what we have so there is still that
process and it's going towards a Tilos
of a Godhead of the continuation is that
approximately how do you resonate with
that I think then the model of them of
the Big Bang is own a model that is
accurate
reasonably accurate within the
parameters of sense perception and
thought it is an interpretation of
reality within the limits of perception
and conception and it is as such a
reasonable interpretation and has
is is a useful interpretation I'm not
suggesting that I love science I have
numerous scientist friends I have great
respect for what they do it's a valid
interpretation and complete your car
literally made us what we are really yes
so it's a it's a valid relative model of
reality that that is useful has numerous
useful applications but it is not an
accurate model of reality and that there
are no accurate models of reality even
that the consciousness only model that I
am suggesting it is false sure that
there are no accurate manners
interesting and that's the idea of the
elusiveness of the mystery and the
beauty of that and to continued Oh
openly and blissfully in complete honor
of that mystery while while
simultaneously being interested in the
models in making and playing with models
that can help us live better lives yes
okay